إذا كنت تشاهد هذا الفيديو ، فهذا يعني أن
الشرطة قد أخذت بالفعل ، لذا فهذه هي
الكلمات المخيفة
لامرأة شابة في الصين شاركت في
هذه التظاهرة في بكين يوم
27 نوفمبر ، فقد كانت واحدة من عشرات
المعارضين.  - صفر من الاحتجاجات المرغوبة التي اندلعت
في مدن في جميع أنحاء الصين ، وهم يهتفون
بأنهم لا يريدون اختبارات مرغوبة ويريدون أن تصطف
شرطة الحرية في الشوارع ولكن
المزاج كان هادئًا وسلميًا كان
هناك الكثيرون حدادًا على الأرواح التي فقدت في
مدينة تشي الصينية حيث  حريق مميت
اندلع في مبنى مغلق قالت هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 26 عامًا
والمحررة في
دار نشر إن هذا هو سبب
خروجها وأصدقاؤها إلى الشوارع وقالت إنهم
اتبعوا القواعد ولم يكن لديهم
أي صراع مع الشرطة بعد فترة وجيزة.
أثناء تصويرها هذا ، تم القبض عليها لأنها كانت تعلم أن
وقتها يقترب من وقتها ، وقد علمت سي إن إن
من المصادر أنه بعد أسابيع من بدء
شرطة الاحتجاج في جمع
صديقاتها واحدًا تلو الآخر ، ومعظمهن أيضًا
شابات متخصصات قمنا
بتعقبنا وإجراء مقابلات مع إحدى صديقاتها
التي كانت تبحث بلا كلل.  بالنسبة لها ،
نحن لا نكشف عن اسمها أو أي من
المصادر التي تحدثنا إليها بسبب
مخاوف من العقاب من الدولة الصينية
تريد ترهيب الأشخاص العاديين
قالت إنهم يريدون تحويل الناس إلى
آلات بلا عواطف لا يمكننا حتى
جمعها معًا  للحزن ، قامت
الشرطة بسرعة بقمع
المتظاهرين في بعض المدن بعنف
دفع المتظاهرين وسحبهم ،
لكن المتظاهرين في بكين قاموا
بالتفريق السلمي بعد ذلك ، غطت الشرطة
مواقع الاحتجاج في بعض الأماكن ،
وتفحصت السلطات الهواتف المحمولة بحثًا عن شبكات خاصة افتراضية
وتعقب المشاركين
ببيانات الهاتف الخلوي بعد
فترة وجيزة.  تخلت الصين عن
سياستها الصفرية وانفتحت في
خطابه عشية رأس السنة الجديدة ، قال الزعيم الصيني شي جين
بينغ إنه من الطبيعي أن يكون
لدى الأشخاص المختلفين
مخاوف مختلفة أو لديهم وجهات نظر مختلفة حول
نفس القضية ولكن وراء الكواليس
يقول أحبائهم الانتقام.  تواصل
أنها تدفع ثمناً باهظاً لأننا ولدنا
في هذه الأرض ، لذا من الطبيعي أن
نرغب في جعل الصين أفضل
ولكن الآن أشعر أنه لا يوجد شيء
يمكننا القيام به.
تعرف على عدد الأشخاص الذين
تم اعتقالهم فيما يتعلق
بالاحتجاجات إذا كانت عشرات المئات أو أكثر
حيث يحتفل الناس في جميع أنحاء الصين بالعام
القمري الجديد بحريتهم
المكتشفة حديثًا ، تقول الشابة إن
أمهاتها وأصدقائها يريدون معرفة سبب
وجود بناتهم  مأخوذة منهم في
كلماتها الأخيرة في رسالة الفيديو ، لقد
وجهت هذه الدعوة للمساعدة لا تدعنا
نأخذ بعيدا أو ندين تعسفيا
لا تدعنا نختفي من هذا العالم
ظلما.